would you eat this it's meat but I
guarantee you it's like no meat you've
ever seen before that's because this
stuff was grown from cells in a lab
clean meat is meat grown by cell culture
rather than grown by an animal from a
scientific perspective it's
awe-inspiring lab grown or clean meat is
slaughter free and potentially more
eco-friendly because it uses less land
water and energy at least that's the
promise okay we know what you're
thinking
that's nasty doesn't sound right I'm not
really into like lab made things it's
unnatural
it just seems off but if the scientist
growing this stuff can overcome the ick
factor clean meat could help feed our
growing population in more ethical and
sustainable ways people will get used to
clean meat in a hurry if it tastes right
if it feels right if it doesn't it's
gonna be a monumental thing to overcome
we visited a start-up in San Francisco
called it just it's one of several
companies trying to bring clean meat
into the mainstream they say they'll be
ready to take a product to market by the
end of the year this is a big idea that
you can manufacture meat in an entirely
different way the big question of course
is how does it taste
we were hoping to taste it for ourselves
but they told us it wasn't ready for
public consumption so instead we watched
as their CEO it a clean chorizo taco I
mean right now I'm gonna be the judge of
it ultimately the judge of this is
milling to people that are eating it
it's really good man I mean I think the
important the important part is does it
pass the threshold a is it really good
it does and B just passed the threshold
of is this meat and it does for now
we'll just have to take his word for it
but they assured us that this is
actually meat so how do companies grow
it first technicians take a small amount
of tissue from an animal then filter it
and isolate cells that they can grow
that means providing warmth and oxygen
as well as feeding them salts sugars and
proteins essentially tricking the cells
into thinking that they're still inside
their owner the cells naturally
replicate as they would inside the body
growing to something that looks more and
more like food
but while they can grow muscle fat and
connective tissue from the starter
strains the big challenge is building
them in a way that recreates the meat
you're used to
nobody's anywhere close to lab growing a
steak there's different types of muscle
cells connective tissue own pockets that
aggregate a lot of lipids and fat and
all of that plays into the texture the
taste the aroma the appearance the
functionality of something in a pan or
on a grill we're really far away from
being able to create this matrix of
different types of cells all doing their
job which is why you end up with
something that looks more sloppy-joe
than sirloin we don't want it to taste
remarkable we just want it to taste like
meat so if we're making chorizo we don't
want it to taste like a five Coby we
just went to taste like chorizo
eventually the goal for these companies
is to produce more complex structures
like a ribeye or in the case of another
startup called finless foods a fish
filet right now it's a scaling up
problem and our job is to change this
into millions and millions of tons of
that what we do is we create non vegan
non vegetarian real fish meat without
the mercury and without the plastic
without the environmental devastation
and without the animal cruelty this
technology really comes in two pieces
the first piece is growing these cells
out in a way that is efficient and also
something that tastes as good as
possible part two is taking those cells
and giving it the same structure and
feel and look of meat that might be a
bigger challenge than it seems
thanks to the so-called uncanny valley
effect in robotics that's our discomfort
with humanoids that are close to being
human but not 100% they're that same
principle applies to meet the uncanny
valley of meat and with with food in
general is when you get to something
that's a highly sophisticated imitation
but not quite there it forces your brain
into a very small window of context
where you say I'm convinced I'm gonna be
eating a chicken nugget this better
behave exactly like a chicken nugget in
every way shape or form or I'm gonna
freak out because I am very in tune with
what to expect we are hard-wired to make
sure that we're not ingesting poison
we're hardwired to make sure that we're
not ingesting something that has
contaminated or something that's even
low in calories your brain is going to
pick every possible NIT that's there
because that's its job but if clean meat
companies can pull it off it could
fundamentally change our relationship
with meat for example just is also
working on a clean meat version of foie
gras that's the controversial delicacy
made by force-feeding a duck or a goose
until it's liver swells up to ten times
its normal size
a practice so controversial that it's
been banned in California but this is
the guilt free version and this is
remarkable and it makes sense that
they're starting with foie gras since
the structure is pretty simple
and here's where it gets interesting
because while science still needs more
studies to determine if this stuff will
actually be more eco-friendly than
factory farming it's pretty clear that
it will be better for animals even some
vegans are okay with the idea including
the folks at PETA People for the Ethical
Treatment of Animals an organization
that isn't known for compromising people
are surprised that a vegan would eat
lab-grown meat or that PETA would
support the idea of lab-grown meat but
you know I think it really makes a lot
of sense when you consider that for
vegans and for PETA you know our mission
is to eliminate animal suffering but
there is at least one big ethical hurdle
for clean meat to culture the cells
typically needed to feed them serum made
from animal blood which is not exactly
an ideal basis for a more humane form of
meat on top of that serum is insanely
expensive and so is the final product
the first-ever lab-grown burger which
was unveiled in 2013 cost around three
hundred and thirty thousand dollars to
grow at finless Foods they've gotten as
far as croquettes which contain their
fish but also a whole lot of potato and
that's largely due to cost when we first
started this project we created our
initial prototype our fish croquettes
that we made back in September that was
about nineteen thousand dollars per
pound
since then we've come down to about
seven thousand dollars per pound and are
continuing to drop it so the goal right
now is to identify a cheaper source of
nutrients to feed the cells back adjust
this is what that process looks like
it's a system of robotics and a
I used to sift through a giant database
of plant ingredients and they claim to
have recently identified plant based
nutrients for clean meat that would be
much cheaper and more ethical than using
serum so if just finless foods and other
startups can successfully scale up will
soon have lab-grown meat that could be
more sustainable and certainly more
ethical than the stuff from factory
farms as long as you're okay with it
looking like this